hallo liebe leute ich bin kari von easy
german und ich bin anja von german
wetter ja wir sind heute zusammen und
machen ein video über den sächsischen
dialekt denn wir beide kommen aus zwei
ganz unterschiedlichen regionen in
deutschland ich komme aus münster in
nordrhein westfalen und anja kommt dass
der nähe von dresden in sachsen genau
und normalerweise seht ihr mich auf
meinem kanal hochdeutsch sprechen aber
eigentlich sprechen die menschen dort wo
ich herkomme sächsisch und das wollen
wir euch heute in diesem video zeigen
los geht's
da machen wir mal neues zwei kaffee
bitte zweck koffein bitte wir laufen
nach hause wir laufen hier wollen wir
fußballgucken anja wo immer fußball
gucken gar nichts ist besser als ein
richtiges leberwurstbrot nicht ist
besser eine resche labor spanne ich
danke meinen kuchen gerne in den kaffee
ich dich gern den kugel in den kopf
ja ich habe nichts verstanden
ich habe nicht verstanden das glaube ich
nicht
das globes gleich ich auch nicht ich
ordne ich gehe eben einkaufen
ich gehe mal einkaufen das leben ist
hart das leben ist hart
du hast schöne augen du hast aber schöne
augen macht deine augen aufmacht dann
mal deine augen auf
ich gehe zum metzger ich gehe zum
fleischer sei noch mal ruhig seit der ma
die küche gleich wird's ernst
ich mache ein bisserl mit schreibe ich
nicht so an ich bin doch nicht
schwerhörig
ich bin nicht mehr herr jetzt sei doch
nicht so beleidigt
jetzt da man nur um die action ich singe
ist
ich sehe jetzt sind wir fertig jetzt
immer verzwickter wir in den lehrberuf
spende bitte was wollen sie gegen mich
nie so an ich bin dann ist schwerhörig
was möchten sie denn mach doch mal die
augen f2p und eine leere uhr stimme
also ich verstehe gar nichts können sie
auch deutsch sprechen
ich spreche deutsch also ich habe jetzt
kaffee verstanden hier ist schon mal
einen kaffee
ok dann eben schalten kuchen zum rein
deutschen vom war ein mädchen
[Musik]
so ein date schon gut gemacht
das war unser video zum thema
sächsischer dialekt und zu unserem
letzten dialekt video haben wir ganz
viele kommentare bekommen von besorgten
deutsch lernen
die angst haben dass sie jetzt
vielleicht einen dialekt lernen müssen
um überhaupt in deutschland verstanden
zu werden da wollen wir euch beruhigen
ja also macht euch bloß keine sorgen ihr
könnt nach deutschland kommen
die meisten oder alle deutschen sprechen
hochdeutsch und ja die dialekte werde
nur regional gesprochen und wir haben
viel spaß damit
jetzt kennt ihr noch unbedingt anjas
kanal abonnieren
diesen link findet ihr hier ganz rechts
und ihr könnt natürlich riesig ermen
abonnieren
danke fürs zuschauen ja danke schön
vielleicht sehen wir uns ja demnächst
mal wieder bei anja auf dem kanal ja
genau